hello welcome from the future once again
my name is Markiplier welcome to Crimson
snow a game that was made to be horrific
over Christmas and yet I'm only getting
to it now
I'm hoping that it's all set up and
ready to go but thank you for joining me
I'm waiting for people to get here in
the past hello
hi
what's going on I'm playing Crimson snow
I just decided that I was going to
stream because I just got new monitors I
don't know if you know me
but I've been dealing with crappy old
monitors that literally broke every time
I turned them off I would have to wait
almost a full day actually this last
time that I turned them back on I had to
wait a full two days for one of them to
turn completely back on so it was a bit
of a problem and I finally replaced them
and now I have this really big vertical
Monitor and it's just delightful and I'm
very very very excited about that
um but how are you good to see you all
this is a scary game set in Christmas
where your ex-girlfriend is trying to
kill you or something like that I don't
really remember what it is
um there was some description to it it's
also in Early Access but I don't know
what that means so we're going to go in
here and then we're going to get uh
murdered by someone I I don't really
know who so I'm gonna go into it right
right about now
yes it's a scary game it does not have
the flying in it but it might
it might just I wonder if there's been
an update that I can hello
I'll be it
hello
that's bringing off the hook
Joyce
don't do well your better half wasn't
around
hi Joyce you know me I live every day to
the fullest
that's me so you have watched the office
again but this time with a regular Coke
instead of a diet oh you're such a risk
taker Mark I
look whoa we've already finished
negotiations so I'll be home sooner than
you think
I took a bunch of pics just like you
asked whoa let me send you one
what do you want to see my photo in the
mouth
I forgot to say that hotel had a
luxurious swimming pool
uh whoa hold on a second how do you wait
a minute
wait a minute hold on I did not give you
permission to say my name out loud
anyway
um
um what are you guys saying mountain or
swimming pool what do we got swimming
pool Mount I can't bust a move right now
busting a movie's not in the options uh
it's a phone call there's not many move
buses to be done I'm gonna nothing is
gonna be busted absolutely you freaking
you horny bastards you horny you horn
you horny bastard I'm only doing this
because you you you said to yeah yeah
sure you just want to see the pool right
and seeing me in a swimsuit has
absolutely nothing to do with it
absolutely nothing to do with it
and there's a picture
what am I supposed to do I only have
eyes for one lady excuse me pardon me
excuse you
yet congratulated me for what
do you mean congratulated me on
Christmas did I do Christmas
I got a letter I just haven't read oh I
guess I got a letter
hmm
it's near the entrance right what what
do you mean it's near the entrance right
how do you know that and how do you know
my name
and this is definitely the house
well I wonder shut up shut up Joyce
I still not over how you know my name
but we're going to get to things one at
a time
man this house seems familiar also the
outside seems familiar as well
oh wow is this a closet yeah
right wouldn't you like to know Miss
nosy Miss nosy by the pool oh I did not
expect that to be the right door
hold on I gotta look for some things
I'm dating Joyce Sophia right likely
story
you lost the letter
I would laugh at you
if I didn't lose my phone around four
times a day
you need to look near the front door it
must be there oh wow thanks Joyce if you
could let me get on with it it's my
house I know where the letter is and the
fact that you know where it is is
bothering me
all right
whatever hello
I think it's in plain sight
by the door
is it too loud no way no way not at all
honey I miss you so much it's a Pity
that everything ended so badly I'd ready
to give us another chance yes maybe I
did some stupid things before but I
won't do them again it's a pinky promise
let's meet and discuss everything okay
I read that
what did they write they write oh you
know
lie lie I would never lie
it's postcard from my it's you know my
parents they just love well big red
smooch on my letters that's
that's about communication
please go up to your bedroom window
why why why why why why
would why why do you know so much why do
you know so much about what's Happening
Here I don't like it
I don't like it what what hello I don't
see anything
[Music]
oh
it's cold and snowy
let's see
uh you've arrived why didn't you call I
could pick you up from the airport
obvious
for Christmas
landed before the storm started
now on to the second part of my surprise
but first
show me your festive mood my festive
mood
uh yippee all right whatever how
I remember
them up in front of your window man you
know Christmas is over right Joyce you
know it's way too late for Christmas
you know it's way way too late for
Christmas
I'm sorry I didn't come to your home
right away but I had to prepare
something uh-huh
what is this handheld Flair
more powerful
okay
if you find the sparklers light one of
them up by the bedroom window so I can
see it I'm just grabbing a bunch of
these in case I have to fend someone off
with fire
hello
yippee
here's the second part of the surprise
for today we'll try it out I also got
some fireworks so take your sparklers
and come over let's celebrate Christmas
together
by the way I brought you a present did
you get me something too
there's a lot of Demands
present for you sorry are you or I need
to pick it up from under the tree and I
won't tell you what it is ah One Lie
leads to another lie so I might as well
keep lying
you won't even tell me what kind of gift
you prepare no okay
the lights are not too loud
by myself everything is perfectly
balanced
everything is very well optimized the
options are not too loud the fire is
extremely quiet the wind might be loud I
am of a perfect volume everything is
fine stop worrying about everything
nothing can be too loud the atoms in my
body are not too loud my hair is not too
loud it's not even colored
you have a present Joyce's love is too
loud I know
I'm not too loud turn your volume down I
have
I'm gonna look under the tree for that
present that I definitely got you I
didn't even see if it was a lie because
you guys are bothering me so much about
how things are loud just you wait until
things are loud because I'm gonna tell
you what the loud really is
all right let's see what's under the
tree
la
I'm kidding Santa
I'll like anything you bought for me
whoop gift for Joyce I bought this
engagement ring a month ago but couldn't
find the perfect moment for a proposal
will she say yes
oh boy
what was that
what was that
what was that
did you leave the house it's easy to get
lost in this weather
follow the light handsome
I'm waiting for you
wait wait a minute wait a minute
I forgot my coat
wait a minute
oh it's called
man the snow is too loud
look guys go on look guys I can't it's
you dang it's too loud out here I don't
know what to just do
you ever seen Krampus
yeah oh where no no no no no no
oh oh thank you
thank you I never would have been able
to walk forward
okay so long as that light keeps
blinking I should be just fine
why do we live across the street from
oh
okay oh good the doors open that's
that's one of those good signs
forward cannot be too loud nothing can
be too loud
is that better for you
is that better for you now
I don't think it's too loud anymore
oh it's beautiful in here what were you
all worried about
this is delightful oh
you guys were stressing over nothing you
thought something was going to happen
[Laughter]
I
hey
is that my beloved is that my soon to be
betrothed well come back here you little
scampi
hey
[Music]
where are you did you sink into the snow
hurry up I'm getting tired of waiting
uh
uh uh inside your house I'm in your
house
where are you house me I'm standing at
the door and I didn't see you come in
hey Santa it looks like you broke into
the wrong house
oh well
oh no
[Music]
oh no
someone knocked over the chair
where's Grandma gonna sit
is anybody home
is there anybody there
oh good I actually have something here I
just pressed F I thought it was a
well good thing
that's there
the walls are too loud
she's in the walls
she's in the goddamn what all right
whatever that was too loud all right I'm
not afraid of you ex-girlfriend
of mine
I ain't afraid of nothing oh hey
whatever you want me to smooch I'll
smooch out do it I'll smooch you come
over here
oh still I know you're there you're
afraid okay
well
that's probably fine
I'm sure I have nothing to worry about
oh food
getting very much uh Resident Evil 7
boys just tuned up there's not even a
lock on that I could just take that off
well I guess not I can't break the chain
so whatever yeah getting very Resident
Evil 7 vibes
oh God but I don't want to look through
all the drawers
but I don't wanna
oh wow they really even designed that so
that didn't clip through they put some
thought into this
who puts plates in what who did this
what Maniac did that oh hey a sparkler
what nonsense is this organizational
scheme
this person's truly
out of their minds I think I've seen
this postcard before
I'm sorry about I can't return for my
trip Before Christmas damn work please
celebrate without me well whatever
that's weird hey I don't remember Joyce
having these photos I thought her
parents looked different you know
I'm PR I'm pretty slow but Mark in this
game uh is legendarily slow if he's not
picking up on the context clues of the
situation
I feel like it's pretty obvious what's
occurring why did that end so quickly
though
oh
who's there who's there is that close
let's close
peek-a-boo
what what is happening well
all right
I freaked out a bit there
but I'm okay
we're all okay
I don't know why that's that thing that
that is that that
but I found a hidey hole
and that's great
huh everything will happen today it will
be our perfect holiday he's coming soon
so I need to get ready dressed Jack
Christmas tree check Christmas
decorations check fireworks check the
ring oh he cannot leave he's already
here this isn't Joyce's handwriting
someone was waiting for me here
well I feel like it's not a bad option
maybe I should see what this Christmas
[Music]
should I hide okay snookums honey bear
I'm ready I got your fireworks here's
you wanna sparkly baby okay okay let's
give it a big spoon Mama come on come on
I love you wow
hello oh
I see you
uh where's the ring
well anyway uh okay so that didn't go
well for me
um
so it's guaranteed death uh there's
really no other way around it it's just
guaranteed death uh so I'm assuming that
I just gotta
just do a little bit
are you there no
no I'm not
oh no I'm not
oh no I am not
I'm not here
smash though
pass
hi
no you don't
no you don't
[Music]
oh don't look down here what are you
doing
no no no no no no no don't do that
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh-huh
you got a little bit of a stumbly walk
well that's just unnecessary
when that's just a little too
that's a little too on the nose for me
ma'am
what are you doing coming back
are you just gonna be there
is that what you're doing
are you
what are you doing that I have to go
around I'm going for it I'm going for it
I'm gunning it I'm gunning oh I'm
cutting it oh God why am I not running I
should be running well I should be
running
why am I not running oh close the door
oh my god oh he's chained I'm dead oh
hey Ma'am why
foreign
I was trying to run
I was trying
I was trying to run it
really was you never have it you ever
have a dream
were you trying to run and he just said
no you don't run there's no running
happening wait I could hide in either of
these
huh
well
you know
all right let's try this again uh she
definitely looked in that other one I
don't know if I should roll the dice on
that are you there
that was uncomfortable
look I I literally pressed all of the
Run buttons that I know in my gamer
Instinct and I I swear to God I was
running but shift don't run in this
shift do not do the run you'd think that
shifted the Run shift do not shift shift
definitely do not
that's fantastic for you
okay
no shift do not press R to run I don't
think that's right
and definitely alt f4 is not how to run
I can't believe it look I I tried I I
did my best I did my best
I I did my breast
look I hear that the more people that
click like on this that's what charges
up my ability to run this is actually
connected to uh live chat and the only
way that I'm able to get power and like
increase my run meter is if people click
the like button because for every like I
get like the tiniest little boost of
speed I'm just gonna duck in here and
hope that you can
can't see me right
right all I see are bazongas okay so I'm
guessing that
if I time this when she's doing her
little liberty lose
that I can
I mean I I can't run there's okay I'm
going
back
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love crawl spaces oh yeah
hey
yay I'm definitely not being herded
anywhere
definitely not being herded
okay
surprise oh okay
uh-huh
door you come back here door you come
back here don't run away from me
oh you don't run away from me what are
you
over it hi Joyce
tree that you knocked over what and why
did
I didn't know how long it took me
what
uh Joyce uh there there's some creepy
[ __ ] uh
I'm not gonna lie this is crazy [ __ ]
where are you
crying
man that dang Corridor it just yeah it
got bigger it just got bigger and it got
bigger I think the door was afraid of me
uh I do not understand I don't get it
drinking if this is
the prank I
mark
is that you
you told Joyce about strange events she
doesn't believe you
well
well she's pretty loud she don't know
the first rule now door
Now you listen to me door you and I we
could be friends
don't be like that door
don't be like that
we could be friends
huh
well I'm guessing that there's some kind
of uh Supernatural event going on here
I am in fact so desirable that even
demons
wish to uh
but
lure me in
with their incredible bazangas
oh
it could fit in one of The Notches of
that strange door I need to find three
man I just got smart
but I don't believe you
oh
let's celebrate together
that was a close one
almost lost my cool there
hey
I don't think your bazongas are too loud
all right
I ever showed you my moves yeah that was
a close call that was about the closest
call I've ever had anywho
[Laughter]
you're still there
foreign
man I didn't like that that was weird
usually they just go away
stop saying bong Hong groups
don't don't speak ill over Blanc Hong
lahungus don't
okay what do I do she's just spasming in
the doorway I I don't know what to do
about that that's peculiar
who
I can't Crouch I can't run what do I do
oh my God oh my God what do I do whoa
whoa
whoa
what do I do
what what do I do what do I do
well so long as she's only looking over
there I think I'm gonna be okay
hopefully you guys charged up my run
meter Enough by clicking the like button
it is in fact tied to it and if you
don't
wow
I'm gonna get caught and oh that's
locked
um
um
this is not a door I thought it was
gonna be a door
oh I hear something from them on the
other side of that but I can't seem to
get there
so what do I um or her what do I am
do about that
um
I don't think busting a move is gonna
help
but she seems oblivious so
I think I could probably do whatever I
want
how much you notice me before
what did I do
what did I do differently
don't know was there something in here
no
damn sparklers
I I
actually don't know what to do
um
I I wonder if she's actually stuck I
wonder if I actually bugged it and she's
stuck
because I put this in here that's not
working
and I can't go over there
because that's not working
and she startled in a moment before
uh
can I yeah can I distract is there a
distraction
I don't think I can distract
I think she might be bugged so I I can't
I'm I don't think I don't think hugging
her is a good idea but I could try it
who is it
well
I I the the right term was guess who not
who is it who is it is what I say in
response when you do that to me uh we'll
try that again and we'll get it right
this time so don't screw it up for me
okay take two take TWA
he goes in here
amazing dork
la la
all right
what a lovely smile where are you
nowhere honey bear
I'm always right here in here
in in right here
let's celebrate together ah yeah okay
let's uh not do that okay I'm gonna
watch where she's going and I'm gonna
just make sure she doesn't just get
stuck all Twitchy like in the doorway
again
is you stuck all Twitchy like in the
doorway again
interesting
oh ah see it was bug
it was bug
I see
see it was bug
so the thing to notice here
is that
I think
there's a way to get in there around her
so when she turns around
that's when I make my move
and I'm not gonna bust a move per se
but I'm gonna make my move oh yeah why
is your clothes why why have you closed
your doors to the public
okay
so I'm gonna wait
okay
so I just need to get around her right
move has been busted thank you very much
it's a very powerful move I don't know
where she is is she right there is she
standing right there she's not
she is snot
now I think I can get over there because
if I get a
she seems to turn clockwise and because
she turns clockwise that means there's
an opportunity to sit in her clock
counterclockwise blind spot
oh yeah
which way is she going she's going to
the right so she goes to the right which
means I'm going to faint to the left but
only when she comes back
she'll never find me
she'll never find me so when she comes
back I faint down to the left because
I'm in her counterclockwise blind spot
why do I have three curly q hairs at the
top of my head
there she is
you know she's captivatingly beautiful
in a way
not in a good way but you know
in some way
[Music]
easy
I bet
oh is what is
because back and forth
it's back and forth
I thought it was just going to be a knot
that is back and forth
okay
where is you
where is you
did you turn around
Make Me Hurt You
foreign
why would you hurt me
wait wait wait oh my God oh my God oh my
God
hmm
okay so she's gonna go down that way
which is good
and then
she's going to go down that way which is
good
and then when she goes down that way
again from coming back I'm going to cut
around this corner and I'm gonna I'm
gonna gun it
I want to gun it
as long as we don't get any unexpected
surprises
oh freaking don't do it don't do it
don't do it
what was that
what do I gotta follow you down here oh
frick oh frick oh frick oh frick oh my
God oh my God
I'm going under I'm going under baby
God
huh
uh yeah
give her flowers and chocolate I don't
know what her preferences are
how would I be able to woo her
okay what am I doing okay you go that
way
but shouldn't all I need to do is when
you go that way I go around and go
further down
why is this so complicated to do
This is absurdly complicated I'm gonna
I've already passed by so I'm going to
wait it back to go uh for another lap so
you're gonna go that way and then you go
that way actually I'm gonna pop out
right here because I'm gonna stand in
the doorway ready because you can't see
me going this direction
and then when you come around the corner
I'm gonna Reach Out
that's what I'm gonna do that's what I'm
gonna do just basic
um
[Music]
oh what's oh [ __ ] I should have gone the
other way maybe nope nailed it
God damn I'm good
give me that [ __ ] oh oh
my God I didn't click on it good
I hope this works
oh man why does the music stop
well this seems like a pretty exposed
spot if I do say so myself we can
decorate the tree we could don't lean
your bong hangalos towards me ma'am
I'm spoken for
I don't trust it
don't trust it I'm gonna sit right here
because I don't trust that and I know
how this goes now
there's going to be repercussions
it's going to be repercussions and I am
not going to be here when the
repercussions fall upon my head there's
the repercussions I knew it
repercussions
okay so I need to strategize this I need
to figure out exactly how much time I
have to get over there so that I can
make it down because where am I going
that's the question where am I going I
don't know where I'm going it's a
question I don't know where I'm going
I'm thinking that as soon as she turns
around I just got a gun and I just got a
gun and that's the only thing
that's the only thing I gotta go on
here we go here we go here we go I'm not
gonna screw it up oh yeah wait yes
oh
where are you going
my goodness
my goodness my goodness oh my goodness
oh
that was loud no that was loud also
where am I why is this not working wait
no oh
bloody handbras yes lead my fate my
future oh squonk
why did that groan like a literal groans
hey bolt cutters my ass that's handy
la la I should get under the table no
I'm no coward
I should get under the table now
good thing there's this doily around it
just a delightful doily
I have a funny feeling she's gonna check
under the table this time
I've just got a really funny feeling
about that
who's got a really good
foreign
don't do it
stop running away this is stupid that's
not what I'm doing dummy you think I'm
running away you think I'm running why
are you hiding you think I'm hiding
that's a little more intelligent of your
guests there
um
it's pretty good you know this is as
good a time as we are made for each
other by whom who made us for that
purpose you don't know we must
be together could you use the elevating
moans in my ear could be uh ceased
immediately
please stop
uh anyway this is good a time as any to
say that um I'm I'm back and I know I
said this in a previous live stream but
also I got new monitors which is as good
as occasion to celebrate as any are you
coming back or what is this uh
uh I knew it okay that's why I didn't go
at first because I thought for a second
that you would be coming right back for
me
okay so if you come all the way back
here that means I got to take this as my
chance to go now
I hate that I have to follow you do I
have to follow you is there a way down
there nope
oh this don't
oh don't do
oh my goodness how are you this
did you just stumble
how far are you going
where are you going
how far are you going oh frick over oh
oh
frick
[Applause]
okay I'm just gonna put the thing in
because I'm worried I think that might
save it but who knows in case I die
again
okay
then I open up this with the old bolt
cutters
I go ahead that was quiet
perfect grab
and take and I'm gonna get
I'm just gonna go I'm just gonna I'm
getting it Full Tilt full speed full
time
bam Wham I'm done a door door now would
be the time to open
thank you
why is it so dark
[Music]
well that's ominous
I haven't seen something like that
before
did you guys know I'm making a movie
anyway
I just finished the script hi box with
Christmas decorations these toys are
from the Christmas tree at Joyce's house
that crazy woman said something about
decorating a tree if I do this then
maybe she will get distracted and I'll
be able to sneak further that sounds
like she's just lonely
wants to celebrate Christmas with me oh
very special
very delightful is there anything Secret
in here that I need to know about nope
okay I guess I go back then
oh so the hallways changed is it oh
ah I'm back here for some reason who is
staring at me who is glaring at me I
don't like that I don't like who is that
who are you
who are you
who are you
who are you I don't even know
oh my god oh yeah right guys yeah I'm
making a movie yeah okay why would I do
that I'm just a YouTuber I don't know
how to make a movie
don't be rude
must move
anyway
I guess I'll go decorate a tree now
cool
hope uh Joyce is still alive
hi Joyce
it's awesome stupid prank Mark moving
corridors what nonsense I know right
your friend in the window and I know
she's just hiding somewhere
she just moves really fast and that's it
it's nothing special yep
uh uh hi it's Mark call the police
uh feels like a dream house changing
some crazy woman would look for me I
think I found your Christmas decoration
she must have brought there I I think
it's pertinent to tell you that there is
some really weird lady with extremely
long fingernails uh and no other
discernible features no other
discernmental features that we're not
going to talk about that is looking for
me
you saw a woman right
but if it's true big if true
you said I need to hide I'll do that and
then
well you better hide it's not gonna go
well for you
it's gonna go fine for me though I put
up Christmas decorations I'm a-okay
merry is Christmas la la la hiding down
under here oh I can actually see my legs
I don't think I could have seen those
before
uh are you is you out there
is you
there's you out there
well I don't exactly know what I'm
hiding from so I shan't hide I feel like
I didn't even have a body before I feel
like that's different I don't know why
but I just feel
oh
much like this previous moment when we
I'm not afraid
well I'm afraid I'm afraid
I'm afraid whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't
think hiding's gonna help me oh hiding
probably was going to help me oh hiding
was definitely good oh Ring Around the
Rosie pocket full of hey
things
I will be right back okay oh
oh
well uh Ohio why is everyone ragging on
Ohio lately that's my home state
that's my home state where you got me to
me no she told me not to move a muscle
she would be right back why
why would I move
why would Ohio isn't real I don't know
how to tell you this Ohio's lurking in
your closet in this very instant no she
told me not to move she literally said
don't move I'll be right back or
something to that effect
so I'm gonna be late I know I know how's
one big meme I get it I'm from there I
grew up there I know all about Ohio but
I'm telling you Cincinnati is a great
place it's got
a symphony
football
baseball hockey
it's got a roller coaster park outside
of it it's got some of the best water in
the in the in the country
at least when I was growing up at least
that's what they told me where is she
she is taking a while
I really I thought that
I thought she'd be right back
Cincinnati has a zoo
now
I know that the Cincinnati Zoo is the
one where harambe died however
it's notable right the Cincinnati Zoo is
very highly reputable Zoo Zoological
organization
yeah yeah yes that actually is is um
true
yeah harambe was from Ohio yeah yeah
all right I know this argument is not
looking good for Ohio but uh hey Fiona
the
entrance
pretty all right I don't think she's
coming back guys I really thought that
she was gonna come back but she's
oh whoa
hello
I mean you told me not to move and yet
just kind of rude on your part that you
didn't come back
put up all these beautiful decorations
for you
I guess I'll just leave then
yeah jungle gyms yeah Cincinnati has
jungle gyms that's very good I'm out of
here
oh
well it couldn't have been that easy I
guess
where am I going
what am I doing
oh yeah
oh
oh God
I love basements and Kings Island you
can't deny Kings Island
oh what does that sound what's that
sound
what does that sound
whoa
what was the sound
there's a strange sound in the air
okay and so many frying pans and
toiletries just strewn about randomly
along with chemicals who has this many
chemicals in their house actually
everybody
hi Joyce hey what's up Joyce
she
yeah it's definitely not a prank
oh man I'm fine
I was hiding just like he said I had
time to prepare before she found me
I
I launched fireworks at her
it seems to have scared her off
I don't think she likes bright lights
try to find something similar
maybe that'll help you she doesn't like
bright lights do you know her how did
she know I was coming to you
I got it I need to find something to
burn proudly Joyce be careful you need
to focus on survival
yeah Joyce uh do you know how does she
know that I was coming to you I gotta I
need to find something that burns
brightly Joyce be careful
yeah how did you know how how did she
know how did
ah you focused on Survival I feel like
that's important
we have to have to we must
do
oh
well you just told me that she doesn't
like bright lights so I think find a
flashlight and more fireworks try to
drive her away with bright light
yeah sure I'll try
I hope it works I mean you told me to
what do you mean
I think they'll arrive here fast enough
in this weather
I will baby
all right whatever
fine just hang up like that you know do
our post call smooches but you know
whatever fine I don't know it literally
she just told me to do bright lights so
if that's not the right answer then I
think there's a flaw in the story here I
think there might be a flaw and Ye Old
story town
it's a barrel roll
I was just trying to play it off cool
that actually did Scare Me it was a
terrifying Barrel
good thing I'm finding something
that actually didn't scare me because
I'm a big strong man
scaring me
okay any other strange noises
that was poor timing okay
Lila
[Music]
Lee
oh hey
what what
ah
that didn't scare me because I'm a big
strong man very brave
very brave no one could ever find any
evidence to the contrary that that uh
scared me because it
foreign
how you doing
all right good
could you just back up
did you just back that ass up
oh you tricky
you are very
tricky
perfect
my opportunity
is secure crap I'm dead crap I'm dead
crap
I'm dead
I am dead I good thing I can't run man
it would be great if I could run boy my
death sure is slow and certain nope nope
under oh I'm so safe
oh
look I can't run guys there's no there's
no running there ain't no running
you guys haven't clicked the like button
enough that this is why I'm not on the
home page this is why if you try to get
to a video of mine from the home page it
just won't work it's because you guys
haven't liked the videos enough and yes
it's an easy equation it all starts from
not being able to run it goes to not
being found on the front page it goes to
being shunted way into the back rooms of
YouTube to be forever purged from the
roles of existence for all the YouTubers
who are bad bad boys
and then I'll be able to run that's what
it's all about and if you don't do that
then I'm dead I'm dead my entire life
energy is sustained on likes and likes
alone
only likes
it's much like only fans but different
all right I have no idea where I'm going
I guess I'm following the wires or
something
oh this is a fun room
what am I looking at
foreign
anyway
I can't run there's no run button
there's no run button
what are you doing in here
what are you doing
[Music]
your ass out here
you wee-woo Iowa
[Music]
this doesn't bother you right no cause
you're stupid
so stupid you're so stupid am I going
backwards God damn it did I just go
backwards oh frick oh frack
which way are you going
okay
I don't know
I don't know how she got there
did I make it
oh
what no no I didn't want to go under I
didn't hear her it's fine I wanted to
pick up the
firework
and what is this all about
hope that's not a choice
I feel I did not have legs before that's
the thing I want to point out I grew
legs
[Music]
at last
I need to get ready
what are you uh getting ready
what are you getting ready come on tell
me oh you don't have to be shy come on
tell me tell me I'm definitely not gonna
run away
[Laughter]
hahaha
[Laughter]
all right I'm out of here later nerd
I'm running I'm faster now suddenly
well good thing I have these wires to
guide my path
wait a minute
wait a minute how did what how whoa wait
what no what how no
it's not funny it's not funny it's not
funny it's not funny how are there two
of you that doesn't make any sense
how are there two of you
did I miss something
there's two of them
that's twice as much Boba as I was
don't mind I'm dead
but
but
uh
[Music]
okay let's try this again I guess
I just love that
it's just it's just very much the Grinch
from the greatest movie of all time Jim
Carrey's out of the Grinch Stole
Christmas just when he opens the cabinet
and the cat's there and he's just and
then he gets caught in the face
hilarious every time Riot is laughter
hey she's gone
well that's strange
that's very strange
that's very peculiar oh hey whoa what is
that there's a key
I'm not touching anything oh I've been
making so much soup in World of Warcraft
you have no idea
don't ask how that relates in any way
shape or form you don't need to worry
about that this door will help me open
that decorated this key will help me
open that decorated key door key door
key don't ask questions
at all ever
anyway la la la what am I doing now la
la la Liberty
[Music]
oh this door
I'm just going for it I'm just going for
it
okay
I'm going for it bro my goodness
that is very useful a whole box of
fireworks if she really is afraid of
bright light they will definitely come
in handy maybe I can set a trap for her
I just need to find something that can
distract her where did she hide my ring
well I was gonna suggest I stripped my
pants off and I just start dancing
because that would distract a lot of
people I feel I feel like that would
bust a move if you know what I mean
anywho
well
Joyce are you dead
are you okay
basement and yes
I'm fine how are you please speak
quieter
I think probably we should err on the
side
of oh [ __ ]
I'm fine how are you
sorry I'll try
I scared her away mark this [ __ ] is
afraid of bright light she left me alone
and I don't know when she'll be back but
now
she's gone
what about you
do you have any news
preferably good news ah
I found fireworks just like you said
my gift for you she took it away I would
have it but God damn she took it I found
fireworks just like you said that's good
now we have a chance
we can do it we can I called the police
I don't know where you are right now so
I gave them my address
find a window they'll be able to see you
from okay cool
I'm in the basement I'm in the basement
I don't think it could stop or I need
something more powerful for that on the
other hand it will help me remove those
boards that cover the household
shut up go away screw you
how are you hiding under there what are
you doing
it's quiet this is quiet oh my God oh my
God
this isn't an elevator this is a dumb
waiter by the way
idiot
oh
I'll crawl right in somehow
I do like making soup I do I do like
making soup
and also I know that I I have started
playing World of Warcraft again I will
not tell you where but I have been
making a lot of soup
I I remember uh how I left people in the
Lurch with the Old Market peeps Guild
and I don't want to subject people to
that again I will
I will uh
I'll keep my silly silly wow ways to
myself and I shall not strand people on
a strange server that they've never been
to before I won't do it
you want to know what I'm talking about
you got to go back into the annals of my
history not not the anals of my history
annels
a-n-n-a-l-s annals
a-n-a annals
the Arnolds Arnolds annals of History
who is ugly bastard the ant
you gotta go into no that's a word it's
actually a word it means like
halls or something
[Laughter]
you gotta go into the the ant the Arnold
the annals right I've never said it out
loud I've never said that word out loud
not the Arnolds of History
not the ass pills of History
the uh the annals of History a-n-a-a-l-s
foreign
[Laughter]
whoa [ __ ]
well I'm not in the Second Story window
hey what's up
hey do we do
bongos
okay
anymore yeah I don't think they've
noticed you
did another window that's more visible
so the police
okay
I'm on it I don't know how I got up to
the second floor I guess with the the
dumb waiter
not the annuals
is that what's on my only fans no
foreign
[Music]
would be okay Joyce
we can do this you gotta believe
we can't give up we can't give up I
heard her mumbling something
I don't know if this helps but she said
something about the gift she finally got
and one more thing I
saw the [ __ ] through one of the cops
through the window
maybe he has
maybe he's got a big gun on his body
maybe there's a huge gun on his body
over there it will you not like that
look
guys it's all gonna be okay you're gonna
be fine just if you don't I'm gonna keep
doing this until you give the like
button a big old smack with full
lipstick you gotta get the like button
or else I'm average
you're panicking somehow this triggers a
flight or fight response well you've
never
I don't know I'm heading into the war
fashion about a fight oh you're gonna
have to it's just drunk because just
talking into his radio show and it'll
probably ever heard of the
what's his name
that's the guy another name oh
my God
all right I'll stop
I'll stop I'll uh I'll cease I'll cease
it seems like she's given up on actually
killing me which is awfully nice I do
appreciate that wow sorry visiting my
family stuck at work
uh these are my old postcards I started
sending them to my ex-girlfriend when I
couldn't talk to her so that was her
that was what did you not recognize her
did you not recognize her is she serious
is you serious wow
oh wow
lotion
uh she's been following me all this time
I have nowhere to hide she won't let me
go she left she won't bother us Mark
bought a ring is it for me does he want
me back Mark doesn't talk to his parents
anymore that's good who does he talk
with these friends are bad for him I
need to get rid of them Mark celebrates
Christmas Christmas alone now is the
time he went to this [ __ ] joycy
wow okay all right then uh I don't know
how you turned into a demon
pointed right in my house
oh you know
uh
uh found a telescope I found notes she
made there about my schedule
I found a telescope well Eve both of
these I think the telescope
both are incriminating
she was spying on me
true
false true but she was interested
uh yeah mark
God I must be some kind of stupid if I
didn't recognize her before let's see
we why am I hesitant about this what
Auto star is awkward oh man oh God
you're oh you're not gonna oh you're
gonna be so mad it's like what what is
she clearly trying to kill us and it's a
demon somehow
we used to date are you dating
well she wasn't a demon before
uh she looks almost completely different
right now I mean
she you're seeing her demonness
well you know how she has claws
not that
uh
I realized that she was mentally unwell
and we had to break up
she was crazy
trying to harass my parents and friends
so I left
both fairly accurate you know I don't
think Candor and delicateness is uh good
here I'm gonna just say straight up
so that's why you moved here from your
city
the things that she does
was she able to
be able to you weirdly know
maybe I tried not to notice
you know she was climbing on the walls I
was like oh man she's so quirky uh she's
so quirky going through the vents ah man
she's ah she's cool
with her long lady
claws I was like wow she really loves
her nails
no okay last year her health began to
deteriorate that that's that's me paying
attention I feel like I would notice
some things
literally why would I lie not why did we
have time for this conversation
I don't have any idea why this was
important
you'd think that it'd be these are the
conversations we have after we escape
from horrible X
anyway whatever it's fine I get it I
must stand up guy
very honest
extremely actually
Corridor key could unlock the door to
the corridor I hope it will lead me to
the gun
one can only hope
to you
why did that run out so quickly wait
they run out so quickly
why'd that run out so quickly
why'd that run out so quickly
well this is ominous
certainly opened nothing uh pops out of
me or enters the hallway that would be
awful
that would be terrible
you cheated on me
shorter than me
well I didn't know about your cool
talents before
I didn't know about your your great big
heaving talents I had no idea
are you come
um
she's not a demon though are you sure
about that are you you're looking at
this same lady that I'm looking at right
here and you're you're saying to
yourself not demon your conclusion is no
demon here no demonsies
no demons is are you saying just saying
that you saying that okay okay whatever
you say whatever you say
I don't know where I'm going with this
but here I go
peek-a-boo
guys
[Music]
I'll take that
windy
certainly is brighter than it's been in
the past you know if you wanted me to uh
rejoin with you
that was weirdly phrased I'm sticking
with it rejoin with you become one then
I you could have um
I don't know
well that's a bad sign
maybe uh
tidied up the place a bit
I won't be back you can stop stalking my
family now please don't hurt them
they don't know where I am I didn't tell
them where I moved I know that your
illness is causing your behavior but I
can no longer put up with it you have
refused to seek treatment for too long
you can't control your psychosis now
I love you but I'm too tired of being
afraid for my family I'm sorry he loves
me
and at the very end I didn't dare to
speak to her openly and just wrote a
letter should I have told her earlier
he loves me all right fair enough
I mean hey whatever you need to do to
feel safe uh I don't think you can blame
yourself for this one pal
and Marky mu here you
know what's going on
do I push this I do yeah
I don't want to know what's going on in
the other room it sounds
very aggressive and uh
oh I'm stuck
what is happening over here
this is far too oh hi
thought you thought you brought the ring
for me
you don't love me anymore
well
not just mine now
okay
um well if you thought that then why did
you kill me so immediately also yeah the
other room is too loud are you guys all
hearing that the other room is way too
loud
the other room is unbelievably too loud
I wish I had like you know how there's
Toby eye tracker I wish I had Toby eye
tracker but for where all of you guys
were looking on stream and that way I
could see you perverts just like
following like the cleavage of her dress
there just you pervert it's not me
though I wasn't
no
of course it wouldn't
but you perverts I guarantee you just be
like you know it's a heat map I'm just
like the circle is just hundreds of
circles
like God if I could know if I could just
see that it'd be incredible
oh
uh
scp-096
let me guess if I Step Beyond any of
these it's gonna cause a real raucous
who's gonna cause a real problem
were you crying
a little bit of crying oh oh no oh you
kidnapped me Rex oh you're doing a
little kidnapping oh you need a little
oh kidnapping against someone's will and
now you're always mad about it because I
don't love you for that oh you're gonna
be all boo oh did you do a little cry me
why me whatever
shut up
sure I hope I don't that would be bad if
I was stepping on something oh you're
doing a little rock in the back and
forth are you having oh are you being
mentally unwell are you having an
emotional breakdown right now oh you
well there's a
there's people you can talk to not me
though bye
[Music]
I'm not mean
it's a demon
she's a demon she's a demon
she said I can bully her look what he
did well I guess you could take that one
way or another but
she tried to kill me
she's trying to kill me
oh so mean oh oh are you are you having
a little defensive onesies of a demon
are you defending a demon you you feel a
little pity are you having a pity party
for a demon oh oh no is she is your
favorite YouTuber a little bit you mean
I see a bit of a big bully something
that's too bad for you
stupid gun
all right don't point it that way we'll
see is it loaded
all right whatever don't do that ever
ever
uh there we go
all right
get ready for a little boom bangy
yeah
I found a gun so I feel much better now
I found a gun so I feel much better now
who needs to be careful
careful now boom boom
yeah I gotta play the Doom DLC I haven't
played Eternal gods or is that what it
is huh
sure now's good
yeah why not what's up
I know it's it's silly but I
I need to be sure that it here let me
pop a squad here
I'll pick up some my legs a bit
oh babe babe babe babe babe
babe babe
it was a big old ring you know 20 carats
I think or something like that
oh I know
after all this
I'll give you the answer so don't you
dare think about giving up I would never
I'm so glad we had this call click
all right time to go kill some some
demons click click bang really
really it was
a little loud oh did I interrupt your
pity party oh you're gonna come chasing
after me
oh sorry I'm having a little uh
a little bit of a silly time
well that's fine
oh
babe
oh come on
I'm amazing
I wish I could see
tall babe
oh Babe oh Babe
where are you babe
where are you
babe
wait
I would have thought that the other way
was just to the dumb waiter
oh
no
why is that dresser is still moving in
the other room there I I must need to go
back right
right
I'm going in the wrong way but
feels good feels right I'm going the
wrong way but I don't care
I I just don't oh tweet puppy
all right whatever whoa I knew it that
was very important
anyway maybe I should call my girlfriend
again hey what's up yeah still in the
house you you still in the house ah man
that sucks
well hopefully we can get out of here
eventually yeah my ex is a real you know
I won't say it but bro you know
go this way now I guess stop being such
a
idiot
fool
I don't know why I'm going back this way
either there's really no other way to go
where else would I go
I mean I got the gun but I mean I don't
remember what the main objective with oh
that's
oh
I never saw this before right
click click bang that works every time
oh
she is obsessed with this ring if I put
it under the tree it will definitely get
her attention I can't avoid this anymore
we need to end this she was obsessed
with chasing now and I was obsessed with
running away
now it's all over for both of us
you're not gonna say something poetic
like no I'm gonna chase her now I'm
gonna now I'm gonna chase and she's
gonna run to her grave
not actually what you said was better uh
what I said was complete ass
babe
excuse me you know how it is blah blah
blah blah you know
uh I think I figured out a way to stop
her do you know how to stop her
let's see
I'll use the gift to set up an ambush
did you find my present
good did you find my presentations
[Laughter]
it looks like she's obsessed with
Spencer uh maybe if you put a present by
the Christmas tree we'll distract her
that was my idea
oh you know I don't need to be careful
when I got this all right here we go
[Music]
uh oh
what
load load loading I haven't seen a
loading screen
well well well
time to finish this
I gotta put fireworks everywhere first
or something like that
whoa
how do I do that
you said don't forget to put fireworks
everywhere first how do I
do that
do it do I just do it
do I
um do I
do I
I'm guessing I just do it I I thought
that there would have been I thought
that there would have been like a prompt
to put things everywhere but I guess I
just put this down yes now I'm ready
I tried I tried placing fireworks first
there's no there's no place to put them
I can't even hide under the thing I
think I just plop it there and it
probably doesn't
I did it I think I hope
you chose me
yep
thank you oh you're welcome
gun use Thunderbolt uh what I'm waiting
for you gun use I'm saying tackle yes
gun we will be
together
where are you dear
oh there's a button
I thought I would have to shoot
what happens if I I can't move I can
only lean
this is all I can do just lean to the
right all right
tidy up so sorry everybody
oh God
Yeah Bang Boom take
[Music]
what
I'm taking this back whoop never mind
yeah dude yeah well yeah oh yeah
Oh weird oh take some of this whoa
oh wait but no wait you were I thought
boy I really thought I was gonna be a
lot cooler in this last moment I thought
that this final sequence was going to be
me just
but uh apparently no um
that ain't how it'd be
so uh I'm just gonna try that again and
we're gonna hope for the best
let's just actually have a doozy over
let's have a doozy over we're gonna have
a doozy over because we're doozying it
over we're doozy overing it we're doozy
overing we're doozy overing
we're overdoozying we're doozing it over
yep
button use omnislash
boom take that
I'm out of here
don't even think about it
how about one of oh god well who's gonna
open the door first me
ah was too quick for you let me out of
here it's still closed reloading oh
where are you
try to stummy
okay this is anti-climactic
where did you go
what
what
what
oh there you are Wham
that's what you get oh you're oh ah I
think I probably just have to hit her a
bunch of times with fireworks okay well
that didn't work
ah and then I shushed her
right got it
[Applause]
uh that was my fireworks
why would you do that
sorry I just need to shoot that
oh no oh no Wham
[Applause]
I hope I have some virus left
I kind of wasted them
oh boy
oh boy
oh
[Applause]
yipping
oh sweet
will Sheila say yes
of course I am dancing on your course
dancing on your Crooks dancing on your
corpse I am dancing I am dancing I'm
dancing on your corpse
but anyway
see I do it you knew I would end it with
busting a move you cannot bust a move
that's what YouTube taught me you got
Bust A Move every time all the time
always be busting
no I'll stand by it always be busting
that's what I say ABB always be busting
moves
whatever
Joyce
babe babe
you busting
babe
babe
oh
busting all over the park
babe
if only I could run babe
wow that's pretty good for you know for
in-game fireworks
what who's talking
huh what's happening my answer is yes oh
yippee
all right whatever
that was very good I did like that a lot
towards the end it was um it was reliant
on uh jump scares a bit more than it was
in the beginning but that was very good
love since that was so good
I like that I like that a lot that was
wonderful
all right well that was a great way to
come back wasn't it Christmas is long
over but hey we got to celebrate a
little bit and send it off in style and
I think that's what it's all about
I think that's what it's all about
anyway I got more fun stuff that I'm
gonna be making soon yeah yeah I'm
making a movie you'll find out more
about it soonish but I just wanted to
Hype you up a little bit about it it's
something going to be very cool not like
my other projects that I've made and yes
but it is going to be like my other
projects that I've been in that I'm
making it in some familiar uh people are
helping to make it so it's going
very special very exciting thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for sustaining my lifeblood by hitting
the like button and making sure that
YouTube knows that they need to fuel me
with more sweet sweet
YouTube juice they injected into our
veins and that's what makes us such good
content creators
yes I think anyway
something like that anyway have a good
day check out my other videos I have
many many other scary videos
scary games for you to check out have a
lovely lovely evening and remember
[Music]
I don't know what the moral of this
story is but always be busting
that's the only moral that we're ever
going to need
okay
farewell